it's so bizarre to me that the left
whenever an American police officer does
his job whether it's a DHS unit taken
down an anarchist or just a local cop
arresting a looter or resting a vandal
or arresting a killer the left hates
that when the police do their job here
in America and yet you look on the
international scene when the government
of China is arresting whole populations
particularly the we Gers arresting them
blindfolding them handcuffing them
throwing them on boxcars sterilizing
them killing off their population
committing genocide slowly but the
Chinese moves moves slowly as they march
through history but committing genocide
slowly but surely enough the left
doesn't care the left doesn't care at
all because China the rise of China is
part of the left's agenda they've been
pushing for this for decades and decades
it has largely worked and so they look
the other way when China's committing
action what you would call human rights
abuses committing heinous crimes against
whole populations there they just don't
care actually the Chinese ambassador to
the UK Liu Xiao Ming was asked about
this question finally someone actually
asks the Chinese about this question
what does he say
he totally deflects this is not the
first time he will show me I still
remember last year you show me what is
happening in Incheon Jang Jinju
let me tell you this Shin Jung have you
been to injure yourself no I never have
you know Xin Zhao is regarded as the
most beautiful place in Shenyang
there's a Chinese saying you do not know
how be a Chinese ambassador that is not
that is not beautiful coverage however
is it you know Xin Jiang that is is that
won immunity Oh since 1990 since yang
has cannot lead chant because of the
thousands of terrorist attacks no canal
that was ten years ago can I ask you why
people are kneeling blindfolded and
shaven and being led to trains in modern
China what is going on there I do not
know where you get this
video tape you know sometimes you have a
chance to meet your transfer of a
presence and the prisoners you know in
any country um but just what is
happening here ambassador I do not know
what did you get this video honey these
these have been going around the world
that is really spooky because he is he's
telling you that what you're seeing is
real he's telling by denying it by
deflecting he's telling you that what
you're seeing is real that footage is
pretty terrifying stuff I mean that is
truly you know hit Hitler s course
Stalin esque stuff you've got a whole
population blindfolded shave being
loaded onto boxcars and listen to how he
changes a story the interviewer says
what is this he goes this is not the
first time you've shown me this footage
so he's saying I've seen this before
then he says oh yeah this region is
really nice right he completely deflects
go it's a great you ever been to this
region all it's good they have wonderful
hot dogs yeah oh no they're really good
tried the iced tea when you're there so
you don't leave a flex guy says what are
you talking about go answer the question
here's well I don't know where what is
this footage where did you get this
footage I don't know about this footage
but he already acknowledged that that
parts a lie because he said he's already
seen it before then he goes why don't
know I mean you know look sometimes
prisoners get transferred no he doesn't
say that's what this is right if this
were just a normal prisoner transfer you
would say well that that's just a
prisoner transfer but he's not saying
sometimes this happens
who's got deniability there and also
prisoner transfers don't happen like
that but neither here nor there and then
he says I don't know where you get this
footage he goes on to criticize Western
intelligence that's China for you that's
what's been we've known this we've known
that this is going on in China for a
long time even as people mostly the left
in America but some more squishy
Republicans have applauded the rise of
China this entire time
so only we'd listened to that Hong Kong
protester who put it in in simple terms
but he sums up the situation perfectly
Oh yep that's about it that sums it up
that's the whole thing but but the left
didn't want to be the left understood
the China was essential to their
political program of economic blow
and broadening out governments beyond
national sovereignty into international
institutions and so that's what they've
done I hope you enjoyed that short
segment from the Michel Noel's show be
sure to check out the full episode
linked in the description or download
the podcast wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
you
[Music]